the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a theory video as you can see by the
title of the video today I want to read
one of the craziest theories ever
written the reason why I'm giving the
video that title is because the person
who sent me the email was claiming
that's exactly what the theory is
I was recently sent an email by a
subscriber of mine who goes by the name
of Zayn Hassan the email contains a
theory that he wanted me to read and
after I took a look at it I figured I
would read it to all of you as well now
I'm sure that most of you have heard
about a new theory that says
Littlefinger faked his death well what
I'm about to read to you today also says
that Littlefinger faked his death but
this one has some new layers added to it
in Zane's theory not only did
Littlefinger faked his death but he has
also disguised himself as several
different characters over the course of
the story so let's take a look at what
he had to say then at the end of the
video let me know what you think hi
first of all I want to start by saying
that I'm a huge fan of your channel I'm
very excited to share this theory with
you let's get started but before we go I
want you to know that the final point of
the theory is a mind twister and the
chaos is a ladder theory begins Petyr
Baelish died fifteen years before the
events a Game of Thrones
before the first episode or the first
chapter Petyr Baelish challenged Brandon
Stark at our Starks older brother in a
duel when Brandon was promised to
Catelyn here's a quote from chapter 40
in a game of Thrones Catelyn remembers
the duel between Brandon stark and Petyr
Baelish when Brandon saw the limited
armor Peter was wearing he took off his
armor Peter had begged her for a favor
but her father promised her to Brandon
as she had given the favor to Brandon
Catelyn had begged him not to kill Peter
and he had agreed the fight ended
quickly with the deep cut to Peter's
ribs which Catelyn was sure was fatal
that was the last time she had seen
Peter until King's Landing did you read
that
until King's Landing she was certain
that slash into his ribs was
fatal and she didn't see him survive he
disappeared for 15 years the first time
she saw him after that duel was when she
comes to King's Landing looking for
answers about brains fall and where he
confronts her that the dagger is his
this is why he betrayed Catelyn and
Eddard because the real Peter that once
cared for Catelyn is dead Littlefinger
however has no ties to Catelyn he was
playing the game of faces he was living
as Petyr Baelish but he had his own plan
and a towards death was a part of it if
you remember in episode 5 in season 1
Ned Stark was preparing to leave the
capital after he and King Robert had an
argument at the small council regarding
killing Daenerys Ned was packing his
bags and he ordered his men to prepare
the girls however little figure walks
into his chamber and he convinces him to
stay one more hour so he would help him
track the truth about John Aaron's death
later he also manipulates Ned's decision
to denounce attain Sir Gregor Clegane
sentence him to death in his command to
bring time on lannister to answer for
his Bannerman's crimes eventually
leading Ned to his death more
importantly starting a chaos if Petyr
Baelish is dead whose Littlefinger up to
this point of the series no one knows
what Littlefinger once or really no one
knows anything about him except that in
season 4 he said my great-grandfather is
from Braavos the home of the faceless
men but that's Petyr Baelish his
background not Littlefinger's the sole
thing were certain about is that
Littlefinger thrives in chaos he sees it
as an opportunity for advancement the
answer to whose little figure true
identity is Littlefinger is three people
bare with me on this two of these phases
were protecting Arya for an unknown
reason however the third one could have
the reason back in season 1
Arya begins training with the Braavosi
Syrio Forel a man that seems to be
training Arya not just how to hold a
sword and fight but mentally preparing
her for what to come next example is one
thing we say to death not today as if he
knew what was coming in the end we don't
actually see Serio dying possibly he's a
faceless man in season two Jack and agar
appears for the first time as a pair
the question is why a faceless man is a
prisoner unless he intended to get
caught because Serio changed his face -
Jack and agar and fallen Aria will
definitely see in season eight a
flashback to see Rios escape to support
this claim we go back to Jack and agar
in fact the very first scene that he
appears in Jack him was looking directly
at Aria knowing her identity even that
she was hiding as a boy what does this
have to do a little figure at the same
time of those events little finger left
King's Landing on Circe's command to
locate Arya along to that fact he was
absent from any episodes on the show as
a faceless man himself Littlefinger did
find Arya however he was appearing to
Arya using his other face Jack and agar
he was returning his little finger when
Jack and was gone as well Jack and
disappeared for almost a season after he
helped Arya escaped Harrenhal in sync
with that little figure was gone during
jackings appearances more importantly
whenever he appeared he was travelling
to war camps close to Erin hall when
Cersei asked him for the reason of his
absence he confronted her that he was
travelling remember there are huge time
gaps between a lot of scenes HBO is so
good and editing than it appears smooth
remember that scene when Daenerys was at
Dragonstone and within a blink of an eye
she and her dragon saved Jon north of
the wall the same editing tricks could
have been used during jacket and
Littlefinger's appearance timing
finally when Arya decides to go back to
Westeros
jaqen appears happy to that fact but why
before why in season 7 songs is talking
to Littlefinger about the faceless man
she tells him that Arya is one of them
notice little figures reaction he knows
she's not he witnessed it as Jack and
agar when she told him a girl is Arya
Stark of Winterfell and I'm going home
in season seven before Littlefinger got
executed my Arya using his own dagger he
did two things
number one he met with the girl in the
stables number two he tricked the Starks
into killing him the faceless man that
is hiding behind Petyr baelish's face
had a plan but it changed when bran
became a direct threat to him he feared
that brain will look into his past and
learn his identity and what he had in
mind
he realized that the danger when brain
repeated his famous line chaos is a
ladder he knew what he was facing now
that's why he needed to trick the Starks
into killing Petyr Baelish his face
brain cannot see things if he didn't
look into it like Liana and Rhaegar
wedding he didn't know about them until
Sam had told him he needed a brain off
of his back so he can resume his plan
quietly he told Sansa when I try to
understand a person's motives I'd like
to play a little game I assumed the
worst he was playing it before that
scene as a matter of fact he's been
playing it the whole time once again
it's the game of faces the same game
Jack and a guard taught Aria and Bravo's
an episode earlier Littlefinger I saw it
so why aren't you happy what do you want
that you don't have she answered at the
moment peace and quiet
however he knew she wanted him dead but
her need of the Knights of the Vale was
what kept him alive for the moment
another danger added to brain's vision
in the next episode the famous and every
Littlefinger Theory scene happened he
handed a piece of metal to a girl in the
stables which is the coin of Braavos aka
the faceless men's coin however what not
every other Littlefinger mentions he
knew that Arya was telling him third
stark danger so he guided Sansa into
catching his lies he used her because he
knows that she's a slow learner just as
she said because only death can pay for
life and that girl who's a faceless man
herself needed to die so that he can
live we will eventually know more in
season eight about the only death pays
for life ties to magic and why the
faceless men don't fear death they might
be unkillable like Jack and angora when
he killed himself before Arya went blind
finally the true identity of
Littlefinger Jack and agar in Syrio
Forel the mastermind faceless man is
Rhaegar Targaryen let me explain this
Rhaegar was born amidst a terrible event
at Summer Hall where fire destroyed the
castle and killed other Targaryen
including hang on the fifth and Duncan
the small the crown prince grew up with
a complex fascination for the runes here
he was happiest yet also saddened by the
memory of the tragedy refer to chapter
42 and a Storm of Swords he did like to
visit it by himself and sleep in the
ruin
Hall of summerhall beneath the moon in
the Stars Maester Aemon thought that ray
gars birth was associated with the
prince that was promised but Rhaegar
later thought that the legend was
associated with his own son Aegon in a
way Rhaegar was the dragon that hatched
at summer Hall Rhaegar was very fixated
on prophecy and we still don't know the
full extent of whatever prophecy or
prophesies he was expecting to fulfill
but it's possible that whatever Rhaegar
read told him and his interpretation
that he eventually died doing something
so if he had that hanging over him for
his adolescent and adult life that would
also explain why he'd be melancholy
think of the idea that whoever is or 'hi
and/or the prince that was promised is
will eventually die doing whatever it is
that they do this takes us to the whole
plot behind a theory chaos is a ladder
the most important point of the theory
we said Littlefinger thrives in chaos
because it's integral in his belief that
chaos is an opportunity for advancement
this is why Littlefinger started a chaos
before the events a Game of Thrones
he convinced Lysa Arryn Catelyn Stark
sister to murder her husband Jon Arryn
the hand of the king he started another
chaos at the beginning of Game of
Thrones
he sent the assassin with his dagger to
make the Starks and the Lannisters go
into war now where am I going with this
fifteen years before the first episode
of Game of Thrones Rhaegar Targaryen
started a chaos when he passed his wife
Elia Martell at the tourney and he
placed a crown of winter roses in lyanna
stark's lap Rhaegar Targaryen started
another chaos when he convinced everyone
that he kidnapped Liana after she was
promised to Robert Baratheon now he also
added five different points that support
the claim that Rhaegar is Littlefinger
number one when King Robert defeated
Rhaegar during the rebellion Rey gars
body was never found
number two no Valyrian dagger when the
assassin was sent to kill bran after his
fall the dagger appeared for the first
time we learned later it was little
fingers as he admitted to Catelyn Stark
he lies and says he lost it to Tyrion
Lannister in season seven Sam is reading
the old books and search for dragonglass
however a page comes by what that dagger
drawn on it if you try to read it
you can make out that only valyrian said
this sort of weapons and they used it to
decorate it with dragonglass and rubies
targaryen used to decorate their
ornaments weapons and shields with
rubies Raigarh shield was decorated with
rubies the day he was defeated that's
how the river was named rubies Ford how
did it come to the possession a little
finger unless he's Rhaegar number three
the soundtrack little fingers theme
music is used many times before we are
introduced to Petyr Baelish his
character many times in key moments that
we learn seasons later he's actually
behind the events one scene that chaos
is a letter soundtracked was used in is
a crucial scene confirming my theory at
the episode's final scene when Arya was
escaping King's Landing as Arie the boy
with Hawkeye ginjury and Jack and gar
little fingers face
aka reg ARS face the latest teaser the
feather Littlefinger sigil is a
mockingbird as the teaser goes by the
feather is a crucial element in Jon's
parentage perhaps the only house with a
bird sigil is Littlefinger's number 5 in
the crypts while speaking to Sansa about
Leona and Rhaegar notice his reaction
when Sansa says
how many tens of thousands have to die
because Rhaegar chose your aunt yes he
chose her and then he kidnapped her and
raped her
[Music]
you
you